Gamze comes down in front of the year
thank god it's a fun show but it's it's
too big yeah it's very training but
there's a lot of good games there as we
got to experiences we've got our
hands-on time with some games that
weren't available at e3 and some of
those have been really really cool one
of them that really stuck with me we
talked about this in a separate video
but I've been chatting about it since
I'm thinking about it since is Sakura
Shadows died twice it's another thing
that I mentioned in that video about
that feeling of not I'm not knowing what
a souls game is anymore
yeah like that's something that has been
lost for a while now since the the you
know the souls born series is very much
like feels iterative mechanically and
that's kind of mixing up things here and
there this is such a massive change that
I just like being unfamiliar with it
that's what all those games are about
that feeling of not being not being in
charge of all the systems anymore not
knowing I'm understanding and feeling
like they're quite opaque and and weird
like it I had a well playing their game
I was getting slightly frustrated and I
had a flashback to like playing demon
souls when I imported it and it wasn't
like clear at all and it was kind of
broken and a lot always as always before
they made any changes to it and that was
one of the most exciting things about it
like that feeling like I said a bunch of
times or just not knowing what this game
is and not knowing how to be good at the
game like this is it like to delve into
like internet speak and and culture like
this is the opportunity for every time
someone's been told to get good by a dog
cosplayer to turn around and level the
play they're leveling the playing field
by going like everyone who's ever played
at all so if you even if you think
you're one of those people that's like
get good you're gonna get your
comeuppance because this is your moment
to get good as well you need to figure
this whole thing out again and that is
just so exciting
[Music]
well for me like one of the games that I
was really surprised by because we knew
like a supermassive of working on
something after until dawn and then they
came out revealed it's like the dark
pictures anthology so it's like as you
wouldn't you tell me though it's like
the black mirror kind of thing like
every every game will be different
different characters different setting
different monster-of-the-week
essentially
all right come on show yourself
[Music]
I got to play it this morning and like
I'm a huge fan of until dawn I really
enjoyed it and it's just it's so
refreshing to play a horror game that's
not like it's not obvious like it does
the lingering dread stuff really well it
had like this cool cast of characters is
really cool like premise you know it's a
bunch of kids that going treasure like
this searching for treasure they're on a
ship in the middle of the ocean and it's
like creepy shits going down and just
the way that like you like the games and
movies thing the way that they borrow
from each other the way that man of
Madonn that's the one thing I can't
really get my head around is the name is
like a sticking point for me I'm like
man of Madden Madden Madden is the
haunting a ship or something so it was
it's just really cool to play that game
and to have it seamlessly like you know
like the camera angles become so
cinematic and seamlessly go between you
controlling the character to like a
little a little cutscene like a very
very brief one and then go back and
you're uncovering all these secrets and
it's super it's just interesting and
when it was scary like it earned those
scares they were just like chief jump
scares and it was legitimately creepy
and so for me like I didn't even realize
this but at Gamescom saw it I was very
excited in surprise and I got to play
that yeah I'm excited for that as well
and seeing and knowing that it was hair
games comes really encouraging because
the snow means is it's coming along and
I see another game like that is Devil
May Cry which I didn't realize was gonna
be playable yeah it was quite a shock
yeah we turned turned up at the Xbox
showcase on the Monday I know when I
guess playable here and you can capture
out what
like I love the government Christ's
series like I'm one of those people who
grew up with it and almost grew out of
it by Devil May Cry 4 there were things
happening in there stylistically and
thematically and the way present itself
that weren't ticking like we're clicking
with me anymore like I felt Dante as a
character wasn't cool anymore
I thought Nero was kind of annoying like
every time I think of Devil May Cry 4 I
remember the scene where Dante's like
doing it's like a John Woo style
choreographed action sequence by the
entire time Dante's got rose in his
mouth and I used to think like I'm Ana's
like needs to be cool man I used to be
cool now you're kind of but like the
community as a whole was still like you
know Dante's the best I was like are you
guys not seeing what I'm seeing here and
like a lot of people might say oh that's
just the anime style of it like I'm an
anime fan like I know I watch a lot of
anime even I was like this is corny now
and they're DMC Devil May Cry came out
and it took some of the things that I
liked about Dante as a cool character
and reinterpreted it and like I'm on
record like as saying I think that's one
of the best entries in the series not a
lot of people agree with it but I think
the Japanese developers of Devil May Cry
can do combat excellently a dozen
there's got a store at storytelling
characterization they they don't create
worlds that serve the narrative that
well and that's what ninja theory
absolutely excelled at talking to Easter
know who's the director of this who is
also director of film I cry 3 it feels
like they understand what made devil
make DMC don't make cry good and what
made ninja theories take on it really
really interesting and they're building
that into the game so mechanically it's
super cool like it feels good you've got
this really dynamic system with the
double breaker it's like a weapon that
you can't rely on because it breaks and
it runs out and that's something that's
different for these types of games and
also like in terms of storytelling
they're kind of taking Nero and changing
him some more and also bringing back
Dante who's like an older we're yet to
see what he's like now but I get the
feeling that they're leaning towards
Dante's like not the like wisecracking
dude anymore because they have someone
else that fills that role and that was
one of the problems
Democrat boys like both of those
characters were doing like he was doing
that while Nero's like yeah quick quick
quick
Nero side Nero said no said no side
quips get even crazier Nero is even more
sad now it feels like there's there's an
interesting dynamic between them and
there's a third character that they
haven't talked about but he's on the
poster yeah and like mechanically it
feels good the world around it is really
weird like it's got London buses and
London like a red phone box exactly and
like but Capcom haven't said it's London
or England like that makes me think like
oh what they're doing this they're just
taking ideas and things that look cool
to create this new unique world and that
was one of the things that DMC Devil May
Cry did write it create had this like
weird kind of pseudo reality that's
similar to ours you know it had Bob
barbers who is you know what's his name
the Fox anchored and like it's got like
this Lily was it called slim something
yeah virility which is you know like
talking about consumerism and how like
so down that guy stuff can be used to
control people and like I'm seeing
flashes of that so I'm hopeful that they
can that they can kind of channel that
and one of the cool things that they
mentioned was like the biggest takeaway
they had from Ninja Theory is like they
reminded Capcom what cool men or stylish
men in the context of Devil May Cry and
that was really really cool to hear so
it seems like they've now got the best
of DMC their micro a game that I love
and they're trying to bring the best of
that and they also they have that core
competency with mechanics so it feels
like it's coming tailored to be like an
all-star Devil May Cry a package which
is really really exciting
perfect timing for me the other game
that I saw it so I did like I feel like
this is cheating mm-hm in a way because
I saw the exact same thing that I saw at
e3 so I saw cyberpunk again because they
were like okay we're offering
appointments back and I remember when CD
Projekt was showing off The Witcher 3
like I saw it at e3 and then the games
come I saw something slightly different
this time right it was the exact same
demo it was a little bit more polished
but the one thing that was really cool
about it was like different outcomes
like yeah the whole the whole
presentation was pretty much wood
forward like there were some of the
jokes that I remember hearing it III
like a journalist's will be glad to know
that in our future print is still very
much alive I was like I remember that
though that was a good day so just
seeing cyberpunk again because I think
when when it came reimagine say at e3
there was so much buzz about it so much
excitement about it and I came with
being so impressed and then like having
six weeks or so to kind of like digested
a bit and think about it anymore
it was I would I still just loved what I
saw
yeah and that was the kind of thing
about it it's like usually I don't want
to see the same thing again but I was so
intrigued by the first time and this
summer I was looking out for so many
more just little things and seeing one
of the things I'm really excited about
is just how differently things can play
out so it's still that you know like
you're infiltrating this psycho gangs
ride out and the way you did it the
first time is you just went in like
pretty much all guns blazing this time
like you basically talked your way out
of it but decided to just kill everyone
right because it's cool when you're
showing off the gameplay and then at the
end it's like your handler for that
mission for example isn't there and like
it's a completely different character in
a completely different situation like
she was a good basically like a CIA
agent and this guy is like some weird
creepy dude with lit up eyes and I'm
just super excited to see more of that
game because the scale of it is so
insane yeah it's like you were saying at
e3 we like I sorry again as well and
it's easy to get caught up in a frenzy
at a place like III cuz you know
everyone's there to see be excited by
games so you're all
kind of naturally inclined to be excited
and you're like your emotions are
slightly heightened and you you you were
in the war room and literally everyone
was talking about on the hour just oh my
god I just seen it yeah and then when
you step back you're like was that just
being caught in a frenzy so this was
like a really good opportunity to like
see it again and select and think about
and like it seems like we both can we're
thinking yet it is impressive did you
have the new weapon in your demo that
was the one time so that was the one
different thing that they had like
there's an area where you're running
through this building you can pick up
some weapons and in the e3 demo they
didn't they just grabbed some guns the
guns that the gun that could fire
through yeah and also like a ricochet
gun this time they picked up a katana
which was really cool like they used it
for a hot 10 seconds but like you'd move
and when you press the liquor but I
don't know what button they were
pressing and activate like a a force
field ability that was like generating
yeah he was it was generating like a
field of like magnet or something Walter
magnet no magnetic field my god his
Gamescom and it was like well he was
walking towards his enemy slowly and
you're shooting I am and it wasn't doing
anything and they like chopped him up
which is like I was a small change but
like still the the way it was designed
they were talking about how it's like a
really high-end katana so you won't get
that ability yeah but I yeah just you
know dying to see more of it the thing
is as well I think we're obviously
incredibly lucky stuff behind closed
doors because nothing really is the game
for you and so I'm kind of hoping that
this is what that's leading to like
they've had the e3 showing you've had
the game showing they feel like they're
in a place where it's polished enough
that they want to show that happens yeah
hopefully like when we know that you
know we're not gonna get it this year
but at the very least hopefully they can
release that video and like like you're
saying it's almost like they're focused
testing that demo to release it with
with press and the people are privileged
enough to see it outside of us oh yeah
it is still hype it is still good
the one other game I want to mention is
an anime game please don't go seeking
which I jump force
that is a weird game because every time
I see it like it doesn't look like and
it's so strange that I bring in anime
characters to the real world
which is already strange and they're
like not doing a scene yeah they're not
doing a thing where they're super true
to the to the source material and
creating this like Dragon Ball Fighter Z
style like really looks like it they put
in like realism on these characters
because they look very odd but like it
looks like the models that they released
for for like you know these different
franchises that people will buy so it's
just the proportions are a bit strange
and there's like the hair looks and skin
looks a bit too real it's like it's like
remember those pictures where someone's
like I've rented a Venus or what it
looked like in real life it's like that
a bit but the thing that stuck out to me
was it was really easy and fun to play
and super over-the-top it was it's in
the mold of those cyber Kinect games in
the rural games that they've done and
you know have been doing for ages but
there's like a really fun simplicity to
it you just like hammer buttons and it's
so over-the-top like all your special
abilities are like hold r2 and impress
upon and that's it it means that anyone
can pick it up and play it and that
lowers the barrier to gameplay so much
and it just means that because they've
got so many franchises coming together
in a way that never has before it's
called jump force because it's bringing
together like the most iconic characters
from the shounen jump you know it's
stable so like having like the Dragon
Ball Z characters fighting the bleach
characters who all can also fight the
Hunter x Hunter characters you know that
so many different franchises are
included and the one piece guys are in
there like it's stoking nostalgia in the
way that I kind of got like an almost
Smash Brothers style feeling to it to it
like you know when you co people get
excited oh yeah they've introduced Marth
or something like that that all-star
kind of battle kind of thing franchise
thing I'm gay I was getting that from
John Force as well and like the
cinematic style of it when you when it
transitions from like a special move
super move into like a arena destroying
move and very slickly comes back in it's
like really seamless and really
cool-looking and it seems like they've
got a really cool easy to play fun game
that like
is made for fans on their on their hands
so like I went from like not having a
casual interest in that game mainly
because I don't think there's depth in
those dial or fighting games I prefer
like more technical fighting games to
being like I could do with one where
doctor think too hard and I can just
enjoy the fandom and like the the fan
service because it's catering to me and
so I am just super hype about that now I
played dying lights battle royale mode
so it's called a bad blood and I was
like really pleasantly surprised wait
because I am NOT like I can know for a
nice huge I know pub G is huge but like
for me I don't get enough time to devote
to like one online game and the one
online game that I'm devoted to its
overall tell me like I really I don't
really play a lot by row but also part
of it is because it's quite intimidating
I find like an overwatch go to avoid
sleep so I enjoy playing it more whereas
in battle morale it's like it's an
investment and then you can just die and
lose everything right so I was kind of
like there was a petition bones paint I
might because I really enjoyed the base
game and they played a ton of it when it
first came out and I've really enjoyed
the battle round mode like because it's
not just PvP it's not in 99 versus 1
it's you know it's you versus zombies
versus AI like God dudes who are
guarding helicopter caches with weapons
and stuff and then there's like there's
only 12 of you in there so you don't
really you basically you don't really
come across other people until you're
ready to until you've got all the
weapons until you've got like molotovs
and armor and health packs that you've
collected while you're going wrong and
so it feels like yeah sure you still
have to invest in like scavenge and kill
and like collecting Bloods basically to
earn your seat on the chopper at the end
like it's not just you going to the end
and hoping that you survive it's you
actively working towards it and building
up to him and a really great time with
it and it's still got a great motion
like the parkour and dying light is so
good and it feels so good to run around
in that world and just like scale
buildings and leap from them and roll
around it feels great
melee base come back chopping off
zombies heads is never gonna get old so
honestly it's like if I'm gonna really
invest it into a battle royale game yeah
from what I've seen it looks like saying
having that kind of like it's almost
like creeps from a yeah so like even if
you can't defeat like hey it feels like
you don't have to just fight players you
can get satisfaction for killing enemies
and and kind of you if you want you can
just avoid players and see if you can
rack up some kills and the resources you
need from other means so yeah that
definitely also appeals to me I'm very
similar in that way the way I like I
don't like the idea of spending loads of
time collecting these things up and then
getting one shotted by someone from a
different distance I'm being like or I'm
out now for 20 minutes so yeah that
sounds very cool to me it looks like
someone else has filled their violence
I'm on my way back now
if you want on this chopper they're
gonna have to persuade them to give it
to you or just kill them yeah you should
probably just kill so those are our
highlights from this year's Gamescom
it's been a good week it's been a fun
week it's been a fun week it's one of
those shows we actually get and get to
play a ton of stuff a big variety we
have a ton of gameplay impressions from
the week up on games wanna come on
youtuber concise game sports to make
sure you check it out
I will see you misspelt in see you soon
yep juice goodbye juice juice cheese
cheese cheese cheese tartlets tartlets